very pleased to say joining us in the
studio the immigration Minister Robert
janick Minister lovely to see you good
morning
um look I I do think it is to your
credit that you have personally visited
at manston
describe what you saw when you did
well good morning conditions are poor at
the site they are improving we are
trying to ensure that as many people as
possible leave the site to better
accommodation mostly in hotels as
quickly as possible you have to remember
this site is designed for around one to
two thousand people it's a site where
people are brought to very soon after
they're saved at sea or on beaches by
border force and Royal Navy personnel
they're then taken to Dover give an
immediate care in extremists and then
brought to this site where they're
processed they're given some supports
and medical care and then they're taken
on to better accommodation it's not
designed to be somewhere where people
stay for a prolonged period of time it
is by necessity relatively austere the
task for us now is to ensure that it
gets back to its normal working pattern
it has a population of around a thousand
or two thousand and we don't get into
this situation again but did you see as
the the the inspector reports shows did
you see people sleeping on Floors did
you see evidence of people including
children being detained for longer than
24 48 hours did you see people not being
allowed to use the toilet without the
door being open
I didn't see what you just described
about about toilets there are people
there who stayed for over 24 hours and
sleeping on the floor there are people
sleeping on the floor on mats like
camping mats this is not a satisfactory
situation I'm not here to to defend that
I've been in this role for less than a
week and my job is to sort situations
like this out and improve them and that
is exactly what we're doing we have
procured more hotels very rapidly and
more are coming on board literally every
day so the individuals can leave this
site we've also put in place better
conditions there so for example there is
now a very good Medical Center at the
site providing care for people
particularly for the families that are
there I would just say that the root
cause of what we're seeing at man's is
not the government right it's certainly
not the brilliant border force staff who
are managing the site the contractors
the catering stuff the problem is that
thousands of people are crossing the
channel illegally and every day landing
at Dover
to know how to support them because our
Asylum system was not designed to
receive thousands of people every day
illegally indeed and we will discuss
that in a second but but simply put is
manston fit for purpose
yes I think it is uh it's not operating
correctly today if we can get it back
down to a population of around double
capacity thousands it's running at
Double capacity at the moment people are
sleeping on the floors and they are
being detained you're asking me is it
fit for purpose yes it was fit for
purpose a matter of weeks ago the issue
is there are just far too many people
staying there today if we can get the
site back down to what it was designed
for which is one to two thousand people
staying for a very short period of time
around 24 hours then going on to better
accommodation then it will once again be
fit for purpose but the problem there is
a task to handle the problems were
identified by staff there as early as
July and probably before that as the
inspector report makes clear back in
July there were Asylum Seekers being
crowded into the facility there were
people sleeping on mats there were
people being prevented on going into the
fresh air why did it take three petrol
bombs and a suicide for this government
to actually fess up that there was a
problem there and start trying to do
something about it now it's nothing to
do with the and you shouldn't trivialize
what happened
that had nothing to do with what we're
seeing at manston in fact the decision
for that individual to attack the the
Western jet foil at Dover actually made
this issue significantly worse because
rightly we evacuated all of the migrants
who had over brought them to Manchester
and that increased the population
already what I can say is what I've done
in position and I've been in position
for less than a week I've visited I've
met the local Member of Parliament I've
met the border for staff there we're
procuring more hotels at pace so the
population of the site reduces I'm
hopeful that it will reduce every day of
this week that is dependent on the
number of migrants who cross the channel
because if you have a thousand migrants
illegally crossing the channel every day
we have to take them somewhere in the
moment and that that is to Manchester
you seem to be that makes it very
challenging at manston particularly in
terms of overcrowding I've only just
Arisen as the inspector report makes
clear there were issues around
overcrowding even at even back in July
you're talking about procuring extra
hotels and that is fantastic but the
fact that you having just been in the
job for a handful of days are having to
do this suggests that when suel Abraham
was asked in the House of Commons
yesterday whether she herself had
stopped the procurement of extra hotels
and she denied that well that suggests
that perhaps she wasn't being entirely
truthful no that's not correct more
hotels have been coming online almost
every month throughout the whole of this
year so swella Bravo and her predecessor
pretty Patel were procuring more hotels
what I have done in my short tenure is
ramp that up and procure even more
because November historically has been
one of the highest months of the year
for migrants illegally crossing the
channel and so we have to be prepared
for that because quite rightly as a
country we want to treat migrants in the
most Humane and compassionate way
possible but it is worth saying the root
cause of the problem is the sheer number
of people choosing to make that
dangerous job immense pressure on our
system because we don't design a system
for 50 000 people plus to cross the
channel illegally twice every year to
them as illegal immigrants on what basis
given the fact that that of those who
seek asylum in this country 75 of them
are successful I didn't call them
illegal immigrants so they're illegal
migrants it is not legal to cross the
channel in a small boat the individuals
who arrive here invariably not in every
case claim Asylum and and a large a
large proportional majority under our
current system succeed but also a
significant proportion do not and a
number of the people I met for example
at Manson were from Albania a
demonstrably safe country they were
predominantly young males who were fit
healthy prosperous enough to pay the
people traffickers and members of the
public listening to this of course they
want the UK to uphold our proud
tradition of giving refuge for people
fleeing persecution and human rights
abuses but they will also be shocked
that so much pressure has been put on
this country by people who are here
essentially as economic migrants it
makes the point it's the language around
this is useful we have just as you
mentioned seen a very serious attack on
that processing at that Center in Dover
yesterday we had the the Home Secretary
describing this as an invasion on the
south coast I mean would you
characterize it like that well in a job
like mine you have to choose your words
very carefully and I would never
demonize people coming to this country
in pursuit of a of a better life and I
understand and appreciate Our obligation
to refugees in fact I've had for much of
this year a Ukrainian Refugee family
it's staying with me in my own why did
she describe it as an invasion when
clearly it is not well I'd say two
things in response to that firstly the
scale of the challenge we're facing is
very very significant 50 000 people and
the number could well be significantly
higher over the course of this year is a
major challenge for this country and it
is leading to the infrastructure that we
have in terms of reception centers like
manston in terms of Hotel accommodation
and Asylum and uh social housing
essentially being overwhelmed was the
Home Secretary wrong to describe this as
an invasion on the south coast I think
invasion is a way of describing the
sheer scale of the challenge and that's
what uh swella Bravo was trying to
express she was also speaking I think
and this is an important point for those
people who live on the south coast who
day in day out are seeing migrant boats
landing on their beaches there was a
report just yesterday from a lady who
found a young migrant from Albania in
her kitchen
seeking support asking for money and all
that that's not acceptable in this
country we wanted to come here no one is
suggesting that safely and legally
through schemes like the homes for
Ukraine one the Afghan scheme that the
scheme in Afghanistan or Hong Kong how
do you get here well you can apply for
Asylum to come to the United Kingdom but
you do not do that you don't well
through through one of those routes if
you are from Ukraine you don't Hong Kong
you don't do that by leaving a safe
country France I mean you've got let's
just take the albanians for an example
across the channel this year have come
from Albania that's a safe country
they've crossed multiple other safe
countries they've then left France one
of the safest countries that we Britain
I couldn't say imagine you can send them
and then they will be part of the 25 who
feel but again you're describing people
as illegal migrants to this country so
Ella Bradman did it yesterday when 75 of
them are successful and they're Simon
can look yes a simple question prima
facie isn't it illegal for anyone who
has claimed Asylum to be detained for
longer than 24 hours uh you should well
you we do not have the right to claim to
detain anybody for more than 24 hours so
acai have you been doing that then well
a site like man said needs to operate
within the law I have been completely
clear to my officials that's what we
must do but you're not nothing we must
ensure that this site returns to not
just a legal way of operating but a
Humane and compassionate way as quickly
in this interview that people are
staying there for longer than 24 hours
why
the pressures that have Arisen there
have because the sheer quantity of
people crossing the channel we didn't
design and this wasn't my responsibility
I've only been in the job for a week but
manston Manson was not designed for the
eventuality of 50 000 people crossing
the channel in small boats if you have a
week where the weather is favorable and
the tides are in the right direction you
could find five thousand people and
you're trying to dress up as a lasting
capacity look I had the Home Secretary
yesterday describing herself as the
victim of a political Witch Hunt on what
basis is that a fact
well what I think is important is not to
be overly distracted by some of the
issues that the press and the opposition
have been reporting to get to the nub of
the issue facing the country which is
that we have a serious crisis from
illegal migration we don't have a system
that's currently set up to deal with
this number of people and we need to
change that
I'm going to say I'm going to say it is
a bit Rich for the Home Secretary to
complain that she is the victim of a
political Witch Hunt on the day that she
herself is forced to admit that she has
broken the ministerial code not once for
which she was SAT but six times when she
said that she made a mistake she
repeatedly made that mistake wasn't the
mistake that the Home Secretary made
getting caught sending emails from her
private account well the Home Secretary
accepted that she shouldn't have sent
those emails after she got shot she has
apologized after she got caught at the
time she offered her resignation as Home
Secretary it was accepted by the former
prime minister that was The Honorable
thing to do once once is a mistake sex
is a pattern of behavior well she's
apologized for doing that's enough she's
accepted that that was not the right
course
would you get sacked for undermining
your boss and then six days later be
back in post genuinely well all I can
say is that the Home Secretary has
apologized for sending those emails I
mean you do have to remember that she
was sending an email which was not top
secret it was an email that should not
have been sent in that manner but you
send it to a fellow parliamentary in a
former security minister
intelligence and security committee so
you know you one has to
um you you can't say this was a serious
breach of security it wasn't seriously
it was not enough for this Simon case to
advise this correct it was not the
correct thing to do she's apologized for
that and now she's got a big job to do
as Home Secretary and my job as her
Deputy working alongside her is to
ensure that we get into a much better
place with migration so we can have a
system which welcome becomes the best
and the brightest from around the world
legally but clamps down on those people
who are coming here illegally because
that is not what the British public want
they do not want to see scenes of
thousands of people crossing the channel
and and the reality is when those people
do that they put immense pressure on our
system and makes it even harder to do
what I think you're you want us to do
which is to be opening and welcome to
welcoming to those people coming for
real extreme situations if manston is
overcrowded if social housing is taken
up with essentially economic migrants we
can't do our historic Duty as a country
which is to be a great compassionate
country for those who really are in need
for illegal immigrants despite the fact
that 75 of them get their Asylum claims
accepted well they shouldn't be crossing
the channel in small boats that you know
we we may disagree on that but I do not
think that people should be risking
their lives they shouldn't be paying
criminal gangs and they certainly
shouldn't be coming to this country like
some of the albanians we're seeing
purely as economic migrants or Worse to
commit criminality in my job is to clamp
down on that a quick look at the clock
and it's the ICF detained you for
slightly longer than I should but I
haven't seen you for a while so thank
you very much